dit il ya deux chances sur trois pour
que l'on revive la crise de 2008 en
billets alors ça c'est ce que je disais
il ya dix jours déjà je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus que
deux chances sur trois si à peu près sûr
que maman elle craque
la question qui se pose plus tôt
aujourd'hui à mon avis est limité la
casse financière
beaucoup de professionnels des marchés
financiers demandent une fermeture des
bourses
je pense qu'ils ont raison donc vous
avez peut-être vu qu'en france le toit
était des marchés financiers la mlf à
juste titre vient d'interdire les ventes
à découvert
on revient à interdire de prendre des
positions qui permettrait de gagner de
l'argent grâce à la baisse des cours
donc de spéculer à la baisse
je pense que l'étape prochaine c'est de
fermer les fermes et les marchés
évidemment ça pénaliserait ceux qui
depuis des mois ont pris des positions à
la baisse donc on pariait sur la baisse
mais vous savez bien enfin on sait bien
en vérité qu'il marchés financiers sont
tout sauf efficient même l'économie la
plus orthodoxe l'économie néoclassique
reconnaît que les marchés financiers
parce qu'ils sont incomplets
c'est-à-dire incapable d'offrir des
couvertures tous les acteurs financiers
pour tous les risques
du coup les marchés financiers sont
intrinsèquement très inefficace le mieux
aujourd'hui c'est de fermer
[Musique]